I finally made it home I didn't film
anything at the airport yesterday it was
crazy but I'm sitting outside now
waiting because Brianne is on her way
home with her new puppy try and see when
Bree gets here I'm sitting here
whitening for brie to arrive Jane you're
not happy are you know you're not happy
cuz the new puppies here look at this
little fluff you come here mom ollie is
on picture in addition to this I don't
even know how to touch it my goodness
little my camera's bigger than me
I'm collared it's too big on it he loves
me held like a baby look at your little
face loves me how he feels all fresh
give me a little back yeah before Jan
Jana's look I see Andy's oh my gosh it
is like the small he it looks like she
though look at you you don't look very
manly
you are so many dad you don't know how
little he is in pictures I'm Jane just
watched walk he's like underneath he's
under 3 pounds
ok ready little Adam here come on he's
very unstable because he's so bowlegged
ready come here oh come here
oh no oh my gosh haha this is all his
enmity come here oh ha ha
Oh freaking so you know that I'm not
stepping Jane what do you think of a
puppy oh oh good good um you alright
just hope she's nice to the puppy well
James scared yeah she's not used to all
this action you're just so cute look at
your little face oh my god holy crap
they're so cute I can't even stand oh
he's going to eat it because it's too
big around his neck we should have got
the smaller I think they had an extra
small I didn't know okay elbows I'll
dress
for Steeler season I would amend go jig
hey you two get of mine funny okay
nobody say anything
Oh baby 1 you up good mark do you think
you cos no yeah that's no ye let's see
less we got to do a mini burka Oh her
face it's okay I'll save you it was me
that was barking we are at the Spring
House right now this is my favorite
place they have like really good
homemade food and where's Bo right
heaven okay so we we just got a feast
for Grandma good like we've got we got
well mostly cookies no genuine chocolate
milk
yes thank you I got great puppy and
pumpkin shots small puppy and pumpkins
hello kitty look at you
kitty slowly backing away
hey Phil so car ride maybe you should
leave me home
oh my god okay guys everybody say bye to
Bo oh say goodbye shape apply I said you
don't say nothing you say nothing at all
you just sit and look cute
that's your job look at us just just
walk it around spinning around loving
life
oh look at you getting dizzy you won't
do that hey guys you bye